[Music]
bursts of solar flares from the Sun
surface look spectacular but they can
pose a danger to us here on earth if one
was to hit us hard enough it would knock
our entire planet into darkness
wait what how can the Sun do that to us
from a distance of 150 million
kilometers away and what could you do if
that happened tomorrow this is what if
and here's what would happen if a
massive solar storm hit the earth it
wouldn't be the solar flares that sent
us back into the pre technological era
it'd be the giant clouds of hot plasma
and electromagnetic radiation that the
Sun spews out this is a phenomena known
as a coronal mass ejection or CME in
2012 a powerful cm II shot through the
Earth's orbit luckily we missed a direct
hit we weren't so lucky back in 1859
when the electromagnetic radiation of
another cm II set telegraph pylons on
fire The Telegraph that's really all
there was for technology at the time but
now our entire planet is deeply reliant
on electricity and electronics if a
solar storm that strong were to strike
today we'd be in a much worse situation
it would start with an enormous
explosion on the sun's surface the solar
flare would zap the Earth's upper
atmosphere with a giant electromagnetic
pulse this would block radio signals
between the Earth and our orbiting
satellites but it wouldn't damage them
just yet not until minutes to hours
later when a stream of charged particles
started bombarding the Earth's
magnetosphere these particles would hit
some of the satellites and damage their
electronics our communication systems
would begin failing but the worst is yet
to come
after anywhere from 12 hours to several
days a cloud of plasma would finally
reach the earth first it would hit
NASA's ace satellite designed to warn us
about the upcoming storm even with that
warning we'd only have about 30 minutes
before that space cloud rained down on
our magnetosphere and triggered a
geomagnetic storm here on earth
hopefully you're not in an airplane at
the time because it's GPS system would
fail and your pilot would have to start
navigating without it on earth the
geomagnetic storm would start to melt
our power grid transformers do you know
what that means a global power outage
not much fun for all us power-hungry
humans down here all the lights would go
out you wouldn't be able to charge your
phone or your laptop your fridge would
stop refrigerating and your heater would
stop heating you up make sure you have
some spare cash because all the ATMs
will be useless
just like your credit cards most likely
you wouldn't even be able to flush your
toilet since in most modern cities water
supply is controlled electronically
anything and everything relying on the
internet would shut down no banking
services no internet access in the
transportation system and no social
media to vent your frustration in we
can't control the space weather if the
Sun were to send us a direct hit this
hypothetical scenario would get real
almost real NASA and the space Weather
Prediction Center keep monitoring the
activity of our Sun their three-day
forecast would give us a heads up if our
star looked suspicious we might have
time to disconnect our transformers and
switch the satellites into safe mode
maybe one day we'll build a protective
shield around the earth to prevent
something like this from affecting us
but that's a story for another what-if